it's the first of July 2020 so we're
halfway through this so far quite crazy
year this is my monthly update video in
which I'll tell all of you subscribers
supporters readers listeners fans of
other sorts what we've got coming up in
July which is going to be an intense
month I've got a few new things on the
horizon and what you might have missed
in June so let's start by talking about
three big things which I do every month
one of them is something quite new but
also in a way quite old I'm continuing
the worlds of speculative fiction series
but in a slightly different format I'll
talk about that in the July section big
thing number two I've started to make
some progress once again on Hegel's
phenomenology of spirit creating the
commentary videos that we call half hour
Hegel big thing number three is that I
should be able this coming month to
offer several new online classes in the
study with Sadler Academy so if you've
been hankering for studying with me well
you've got an opportunity so what took
place in the month of June obviously
because of Co vid 19 we have been
spending a lot of time inside the only
time that I tend to go outside is for
walks masked up and for various
appointments and picking up things from
pharmacies every event that I have done
accordingly has been an online event and
you can generally see videos of each of
these we'll cover that more in the video
section but I do my usual monthly AMA my
my public Haegele Q&A and discussion
session I started a new series of events
on political theory and applications
obviously you know the wisdom for life
radio show has been going like
gangbusters with me and my co-host Dan
Hayes
recording them for Riverwest radio our
local community radio station and the
classic metal class had its third class
session as well so that's going along
quite quite you know well and and
consistently I had a few other things
come out this month that had been
sitting for quite a while
the deth hangout podcast released their
episode that we had recorded on
existentialism and David's story had
recorded a interview with me back a
couple years ago and he finally brought
it out so if you want to hear about my
views on the Academy and doing
philosophy outside of the Academy you
might want to check those out I'll put
links to those down below I've been
doing a lot of online teaching I know a
lot of people think that that summer is
downtime for for academics and for most
academics it is for me it's just as
packed as the regular semester is I just
finished teaching a business ethics
class online with Marquette University
we're about halfway through our ethics
class with Milwaukee Area Technical
College and in the end of June we
started the intro to philosophy class
online for Milwaukee Institute of Art
and Design so I've got a lot on my plate
that way and I've also been picking up
interestingly a lot of new tutorial
clients and continuing on with older
clients I've also picked up some some
new philosophical counseling clients as
well so that has kept me quite busy in
my schedule quite packed for the
Sadler's lectures podcast I you know
produced some things that I early
released in my patreon supporters not to
the general public in the month of June
including some some lectures on John
Rawls and his theory of justice and one
special one on Hanah Arendt but I did
publicly release the Immanuel Kant
groundwork for the metaphysics of morals
episodes and the Aristotle nikka McCann
ethics primarily books three and four
episodes as well on the virtues and
we're still in the middle of releasing
those shot a lot of video footage
you know each of those events and
classes are available as videos so I
don't have to go back over the listing
of those I also shot something else that
was kind of cool so I've been
experimenting with you know moving
things around in playlists and one of
the things I realized is that YouTube
video playlist you really need to create
a video at the start of it saying what's
this playlist about because otherwise
people are often quite confused so I did
that with two of the lecture series that
I did for the Kingston Public Library
way back when we lived in New York so
that's going five years ago the
understanding anger series and the
glimpses of existence series and those
you know I think served their purpose
short little talk with me in front of
the track board discussing what the
series was about and what they're gonna
find in it then I also shot some core
concept videos on I finished out the
Heraclitus sequence and I shot a number
of videos on Senecas letters mostly
having to do with issues concerning
virtue so that's what what I did you
know in in in June the one other thing
that I will say and I mentioned this in
the three big things is I did get around
to creating new content on Hegel I'm
very happy to say that I didn't get you
know a full six videos done but I got
two really solid commentary videos and
Hegel's phenomenology of spirit in the
morality section so now we've got some
momentum going getting one done is is a
bit of an achievement it takes me about
you know five hours of plotting things
out to shoot each one and that's hard to
find at that time but getting to done is
even better it's twice as good so a lot
done in in the month of June I think
that the month of July is going to be
even more packed than the month of June
my wife and I were joking about it and
and she was talking about it be
sort of like a boot camp for us not only
is there a lot of academic and and sort
of public philosophies stuff to do we're
also trying to whip this apartment into
shape in various ways you know take
things out of boxes and and figure out
what to do with them you know make some
resolutions about a lot of things so
it's a good thing it's got 31 days
events let's talk about those first all
of the events are going to be online
of course because we're still here in
the City of Milwaukee in a stay at home
order thankfully and it looks like you
know cases of kovat are still on the
rise so we're not getting out of this
bucket anytime soon all of the online
events are in central time so when you
hear me talk about the day and the time
and you can click of course and look
down you know in the video description
and see when and where they're going to
be and also you can go to my reason IO
calendar and see the events there as
well so wisdom for life the radio show
goes every Saturday at 4:00 p.m. you can
listen to it you know worldwide you just
need to click on the listen here button
on the show a thing or on Riverwest
radio itself you can even say hey Siri
play WX RW and it'll it'll play it for
you so four o'clock
Diana Hayes and I discuss topics of
applying philosophy in in ordinary life
and you know a whole variety of
different things
this coming Saturday we're going to be
talking about what is stoicism so you
might want to tune into that one on the
7th at 6:00 p.m. we'll have our MKE
Sophia that's Milwaukee Sophia Sophia is
the Society of philosophers in America
we're gonna be having a chapter meeting
discussing you know what Sophia is what
public philosophy is and talking about
the events that we want to do through
the rest of the year assuming you know
that that we're going to be in covent
times on the 8th at 5:00 p.m. we have
our
like Hegel Q&A and discussion session
people show up and they want to talk
about Hegel and related topics and it's
you know you can bring whatever you want
it you don't have to know a lot of Hegel
in order to do that everybody is welcome
on the 11th at 12 p.m. we will have our
monthly AMA that's ask me anything
session obviously you want to get your
questions in early and you know make
sure that you you don't ask the same
question over and over again because
then I just I kind of skip it I try to
get as many people's questions answered
as I possibly can we never get to all of
them so you know again you want to get
your question in fairly early later on
that day at 2:00 p.m. we have a perk for
patreon supporters the philosophy chat
where they do video conferencing with me
and they can talk about anything that
they want to so it's live interaction
with me available for patreon supporters
at a certain level the 12th at 12 p.m.
streaming live on YouTube we're going to
have the next political theory and
application discussion I haven't yet
decided what particular topic we're
gonna focus on but it'll be something
from classical political theory and
we'll talk about its application in the
world of today on the 18th at 12 p.m. we
have our classic metal class I'll be
joined again by Scott truly hopefully I
actually have to check the schedule see
if you can make it if not I'll be flying
solo discussing things where where music
history and philosophy and the music
itself of heavy metal you know could
coincide and connect I do some
presentation then we have some Q&A and
discussion on the 25th we've got sort of
a doubleheader event and this is that
one of the new big things so in the past
I had these sessions hosted at the
Brookfield public library called worlds
of speculative fiction doubtless many of
you are familiar with these we've got 43
videos in the
because you know I didn't make every
single month sometimes they were
illnesses or things like that but
generally I did and we've talked there's
a original introductory one and then
we've talked about 42 different
speculative fiction authors very wide
range and we had a quite engaged group
what I'm gonna be doing I've decided you
know we can't actually have them at the
library and and we probably can't for
quite a ways to come because can't pack
all these people in the room I'm going
to start doing them online and so what I
would have got in mind is to shoot a
video of me talking about the particular
author we're gonna start with cordwainer
Smith and his one novel oops that he
wrote no Strela and his instrumentality
of man instrumentality of humanity
series that a rediscovery of man you can
find it all on this one volume is great
author he actually wrote under a couple
different pseudonyms I'm gonna do a
video where I'm gonna talk about him and
philosophical themes in his work and
then I'm going to premiere that video
and people are gonna have the chance to
talk about it in the premiere then
following that we're going to have a
online video conferencing Q&A session
where people can pop in and ask
questions or make comments about
cordwainer Smith and his great ideas and
characters and plots and novels and all
that sort of stuff so if you're
interested in that you stay you know
tuned and I'll be posting about it and
you can join in if you'd like to what
else do we have coming up on the 30th at
6:00 p.m. we'll have the Milwaukee stoic
fellowship meeting and we will be
finishing up our look at Sonia's Rufus's
lectures and talking about some stoic
practices and other things that we might
want to do and that finishes up the
month this month I'm going to be
still again teaching online I'll have
three classes going I've got a little
bit of a brief interlude right now
before the next Marquette business
ethics class starts up the Milwaukee
Area Technical College class will finish
at the end of the month
the Milwaukee Institute of art of design
class will continue on through into
August and then I have to start
designing my classes for fall because
I'm teaching online this fall as well so
there's a lot to do there I've got some
writing projects going on including
editing a volume for stoicism today
we're hoping to bring that out maybe by
the end of the year we're in the very
beginning stages of that a lot of
tutorial sessions going on a lot of
philosophical counseling going on as a
matter of fact I have some some new
clients that want to bring me in and
even one who wants me to do some
consulting so I've got a lot with that
with the podcast I'm going to continue
on and finish out those Aristotle pieces
on the different virtues then I'll be
releasing the Rawls ones that I early
release the patreon supporters they've
won a rent one and then we'll have a
vote again some of you may be familiar
with this I asked my viewers subscribers
listeners hey here's some options what
should we do next and I do that in
Twitter in YouTube and in other venues
as well although I think I might direct
everybody towards Twitter in that case
so that we have everything aggregated in
in one spot video work I'm going to be
doing a lot of video work this month I
have four review videos plotted out
beginning with this one more than
happiness by tonyia McCarl she gave me
that quite a while back to review then
we're gonna switch up gears a little bit
and do hyrum Crespo's tending the year
epicurean garden a really interesting
look about how to apply epicureanism in
one's life we're gonna do midlife a
philosophical guide by Kieran Satya and
this is another one that I got recently
by Jay David Feldman on being me it was
sent to me by the publisher it's
actually quite short but but quite rich
so we'll be reviewing those obviously
I'm going to be shooting more half-hour
hagel videos over the course of the
month
there's the event videos you know the
classic metal class the AMAs each wisdom
for life episode we try to get good
video footage of that for you
the new political theory and application
one that'll be airing as well because
that's a live event I'm going to be
shooting some more of those intro to
playlist videos as well maybe I'll shoot
for two of them this month and I'm gonna
try to do some more personal videos as
well letting you into some of my life
and telling you a bit about my back
stories and you know experiences and
ideas about things core concept videos
you're gonna see a few 100 offs for
example I'm doing one on you know Robert
Nozick's experience machine I'm not
gonna be doing a whole bunch of other
stuff from from anarchy utopia what's
blanking on the other name and Anarchy
state utopia but I'm doing one because I
need it for my class likewise I'm doing
a couple on Hanah rent on Eichmann in
Jerusalem but the the big stuff that I'm
going to be doing for core concept and
releasing quite a few of these are Humes
inquiry regarding human understanding I
shot some videos on that a while back
but need to shoot some more of the ones
I had scheduled I've got some additional
ones on cow Moos mythos if assists that
I need to bring out and if I can get to
it I'm gonna be shooting some on mills
on liberty as well you remember that I
produced quite a few of them on Mills on
Liberty but I really only got about
halfway through the work so there's
there's quite a few that also need to be
done as well so that's what's coming up
in July if you want to again stay on top
of the events you look at my Facebook
page I tend to keep that pretty well
updated and look at the reason IO event
calendar hope that I see you in
the online events and I look forward to
engaging in philosophy with you
you